ennemi public numéro un homme le plus
recherché en france dans les années 70
jacques mary n'a été l'auteur de
plusieurs braquages
il reprend vit aujourd'hui sous les
traits de félix boutillon étudiant en
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin
[Musique]
j'en ai terminé
il est charismatique lille et meaux il
est complètement il est violent il veut
il peut se montrer violent il peut se
montrer complètement complètement hors
de lui comme s'il est énervé mais c'est
un gentleman pour sa reconstitution
annuel l'association juris tribune a
choisi le procès de jacques mesrine
les témoins se succèdent à la barre face
à eux deux doctorants dans lé rôle de
procureurs et avocats de la défense
la vice doyenne de la faculté de droit
de l'université versailles saint quentin
mari et ma boursiers dans la peau de la
présidente de cour d'assises c'est dans
l'intérêt de protéger la société contre
ce genre d'individu que vous devez le
condamne à deux la réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité
le jury
même verdict qu'en 1977 le shaq mérine
de 2017 est condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion assortie d'une mesure de
sûreté de 10 ans et d'une amende de 150
mille francs
ces procès revisitée sont organisés
depuis dix ans et attire toujours autant
d'étudiants leurs intérêts mettre en
pratique le droit mettre en pratique sa
culture juridique d'une autre manière
découvrir le drap le droit bas au
travers de deux professions juridiques
finalement qu'on aura que pour beaucoup
avec un peu de chance on réalisera plus
tard et voilà c'est vraiment pour moi le
réel intérêt et même redécouvrir des
affaires qui finalement ont marqué
l'histoire
c'est toujours intéressant de voir des
cas concret parce que on a beaucoup de
théories et ça permet de voir plus
concrètement à quoi ça correspond à
procès les procédures et savoir comment
ça se passe réellement puisque si on
veut être avocat ou magistrat sans
assister à des procès ça n'a pas
d'intérêt
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour un
nouveau procès une nouvelle affaire